بين كتبي هذه المراجع والقرى كسرت العلاقه
لسنين في ظل الحرب ووضع الكتاب جانبا لكن
تلك العلاقه تستحضر اليوم تدريجيا كما
يبدو في المعرض الاول هذا لجامعه تعز معرض
يحاولون فيه السعاده نشاطا ثقافيه تراجع
كثيرا في الاعوام السابقه
للقراءه الالكترونيه
وبسبب الحرب طبعا اغلبيه المشاركين كلهم
دخلت المحافظه
مقدرش نتواصل دور النشر
بالحصار صعب التواصل عندنا
في السياسه تصل الى خمسه دولارات لانه
درتها ربما فالحرب هو الحصار يقول هؤلاء
اعاقبوا الذهب
خارجيه عن المدينه من المشاركه في المعرض
التي المدينه او تغطي حتى اليمن بشكل عام
مشاركات خارجيه وعربيه ولكن نتيجه للحصار
القائم على مدينه تعز ساره من المهم اقامه
مثل هذه المعارض كمتنفس همم لاهل المدينه
ولطلابنا وفضيل وضع الحرب وقد انه كتب
جديده نستفيد فيها نلبي فيها معارفنا
وافكارنا اكثر من الفج كتاب يحملون مضامين
ثقافيه وادبيه واجتماعيه وضعها المعرض
اليوم في متناول القراء ليس الا للصناعات
التبادل الثقافيه في الجامعه وخارجها سعيد
العربيه تعز